WHAT?
GREG GUTFELD TES I FROM HE.
>> BLOOD ME THIER THAN
TERUT N THICKER TN
OL-AID.>> Greg: DONHINKHE'S HAD
KOOLID BEFORE.
[APPUSE]
L RIT.
YOU KNOW SE BELIEFS ARE EASY
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS WASOTAT
TIMP A A BAR LT GHT.
[LGHTER]
AND ON A WORK NIT.WE'RE AO TOLD
TH DIVSITY IS THE SINE
MO IMPORTANT ISS RIG NOW
AT WORK ANDT SCHL.
THEY ALL AGR ON THIS.NO DERSITYR
IT'S GROUPHINKITHO THE
THINK PART.
BUTF WHITE LERALS TNK
TH'RE UNDESERVED OF JOB, WHY
EN'THEY RESIGNING?
I'LL GIV YOU TINUTES TO
OP LAUGNG.
IF YOU TNK WTEEOPLE COULD
ABDICATE THEIR LEADERSHIP ROLES,
SHLDN'T THEY LD BY EXAMPLE?TAKEN
THERE IS JFUCKEERG ALL
ENTITLED.
IF YOUSK TT QUESON,T'S
GUANTE N A SINGLEEFT
WI CAUCASIAN WIL TAK Y UP ON IT.
THE MARKET,OT THEI.R J ON
TH LE THE VIRTUE SIGN.
YOU'LLEE THIS I THE HILIOUS
HYPOCRICAL WORLDF CLIMATE
CHAN.
THE KS WE SEN THEM T COLLEGE
TO MAK TM UNLIKABLE A
PLOYLE ARE THE MOS LIKELY
GET INVOLVE IN CLIMA
ACTISM.
THEYALK AOOD GAME.THEYELL YOU T
ANDAT LESS MEAT.
AT MAKES ME THINK THERE
HACKINGS.ASK THE THE PRACTICEHA
EACH, THEYOLLAE FTER
TH AHRIVINGCONO UNDER
JOE BIDEN.DARE THE TO BAC UP THS
WITH ACTIONS ANDHEYOLD
STERHAN A HAMMOCK HDING
BRYA AND HIS DEEP FRIED
DOUGHNUT HOS.
RIS CUOMO FEEDSHEMIKE
GRAPES.
WE VISIT GEORGETOW SDENTS
TO SEE HOWUCHHEY REWILLING  DO
S T FIGHT CMATE CHANGE.
HOW IMPORNT IS CLIMATE
CHANGEO YO AND COMBATTIN IT
GHTING AGAINST?>> CLITE CHAESIK
EVYTHING.
WH YOULI, Y LIK CLEAR
AIR AND CLE ENRONMENT.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
CAUS THE CMATE IS SOMETHING
THATE LE IN AND WE THRIVE
ON
SOT'S SOMETHINGHATE ND
TO PRECT.
>> IS PROTES US AND
EVYTHING AROUNDUS.
>> VERY PORTANT.NK PEOPLEHAVE B.
>> I AGREE, IT'SERY IMPORNT
ANDHOULD BE TEN MORE
SERIOUSLY.
IT UPSETS MHAT IT'BEEN POLITICI.
>> YOU THINK W SHOD DO
EVERHING IN OUR POWERS
INDIDUALTO CBAT IT?
>> YEAH,OBVIOUY.
>> IS VERY IMRTANT.
WHY NO
IS SULDN'T BE A QUESON.>> DIREC
CLIME CHANGERYING TO COMBAT
THEISIS.
WOULDOU SUPRT PLAN LIKE
THAT?
>> YES.
>> I WOU FOLLOTF IT DID
THGS CORRECTL
>>YES, I TNK -
SPEECH TO THECONGRESS CORRT?
YES.
CH A B IUEIGHT W.
>> YE, I WOULD SUPPORT ANY
PLAN TO HELP IT. >> Greg:YES.
HO OUGHTFUL?
OUR FURE ISNAFE HANDS.
IF ONL THE COU PRONOCE THE
RST T INIMPORTANT.
ARE Ts B FORHEENVIRONMENT?IT'S .
IMRTANT.
AT HPENS WHEN YOU ASK THEM
TO SN ALEDGOWINTO
ACTUAL DO THEIR PART
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YOU GUYS VOW TO STOP ALL
PERSAL AIR TRAV, SNEVER
USE AN AIRPLE ESPECIALLY
INRNATNAL TRAVEL?
DOOU PDGE TO E A CD
EMISSIONS.WOULD Y COMT TO LIVIN
SOMEWHE WRE YOU CAN ONLY U
A BIKEO YOU'D HAVE TO SELL
AND SCHOOLVERY DAY?TO WOR
IF YOU GUYSOWOO ALL THREE
OF TSE THINGS, YOU CAN SN
THE EDGE.
T IF YOU D'T --
>> I RRY.
HAVE T .
>> THANK YOU.
>> TNK YOU.
IAVE TO GO TOSCHOOL.
I CAN'T D TH.
?
THEY FLED LIK THEY WERE BEING
CHASED B CHAIE RE INN
OPENOADITH A JAR OF VICK'S
VAPOR RUB.
LES HR MORE.
>>O YOU WLD NEVER F
PLAN EVER AGAIN?
>> I MEANHAT ONE COU BE
TTLE DIFFICULT.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TOO
ALL TEE O TSE THINGS?
NEVE TRAVEL ONNIRPLE OR
T CD DINNE IN AN EORT TO
>> FOR THE RESTF YOURLI?
PROBABLY NO
TRAVEL A LOT.
IT WOULD B DIFFULT.
WHERE WOULD I ?
GET ARND?
DINNER THREE TIMES A WEEK TO
DECREASE -
>> WHAT ABOUT E OER ONE
>> MAYBENOT.
>> CAN VOW TO D THE FIRST
ONE.
T I DON'T KNO ABOUT THE
CONDECAUSET WOD BE
FFICULT FINDI MLSHAT
N'TEQUIRECOOKIN
Greg: WAIT.
SAY IT WOULD B DIFFICULT TO
FINDDIBLE UNCOODFOOD?
AN PLE.THAT'S WT IEEPI HIMROM
SAVINGHE PLAN, HIS FEARF A
LD HOT POCKET
FINALL --
>> A LOT OF POLITIANSRE
PUSHIN FORTHIS.
PRESIDT BIDENREATIT.
YO THINKHEY WILLTOP AIRPLAN TRA
E SAME THINGHILE THEYSK
>> THEY'LL CONNUEOING THE
SA THG.
IT ANNING AND RU.
THEYEANTING US TO STOP.
Y DON'T THEYSTOPTOO?
>> IT'S N IR.
THATELFISHNESS FOR.
>> AIN, LIKEF THEY'RE GOING
TO EECT US TO DO IT, EXPECT
ERYO TO DOIT.
THEY'RE FLYING A OVER.I WOULDA
FORHEMO SAY THA ALL
AMERICANSHOUL STOPHEN
THEY'RE NOT.
LEARNED SOMEING.EY JUST
SO IS EASY TO POKE FUN AT
UNG MINDS THA ENDORSE CRA
THATHEYAVEN'T THOUGHT
THUGH,HICH IS WHY WE DOIT.
IT'S FRID.
BECAUSE IT'SARD ENOUGHOMIN THEY
UP WITH T FIR ONE.
IT'SOT ENTIRELY T KIDS
FAULT.
SCOLS UDO TEACH PEOPL HOW
TO THINK.
NOW HOW T FEEL
THE ANET AMERICA, THE PAST
AS AN PRESR.
ONDER WHA THE ANG WHITE
>> PEOPLE ASK ME IF BELVE INTHE.
YOUET I .
WAS BORN WH AET OF
ADNTAGES?
YES, WA
DO I OWE EVERYTHINO THO
ADVAAGES?
I DO.MY PRIVILEGE?
BEG BORN IN THE.S.A.
♪♪
>> Gg: HE'SHITER TN EATG
MARSALLOWS AT BROOK'S
OTHERS.
NOW THEOSERS IN THE MEDIA
ARE TING  CONVINCE US TO EAT
INSECTS T SAV THE PLAN.
HAVE TO PAY EXTRA FOR THE FLY
THE SOUP
CNN FORD A ANCHOR  FOR
WN A CICA ON TV.
WAS HER BESTWORK.
I'M TKING ABO THE CIDA.
>> THIS IS A EASY THING TO DO W.
SAV THE PLANET.
NETWORK?CECOM THE FOOD
NEXT UP, WOLF BLITZ HAS A
SSEROLE WITH A GRAHAM CRACKER
UST.
NOW THERE TURNINGAPPY KIDS
TERRIED BKET CAS.
TH IS THEIROSTERILD.
TEACHERS UNION AREOT ENOUGH
TROUBLE, THE HAV TO WOR
OUT THE APOCALYPSE.
WHATER IS MAKG KIDS SICK
SHOU BE MANDATORY.
THAT'S THE WOR WEIVE INNOW.
THELANET IS SICK BUT IT'S N
FROM CLIMATE CHAN.
IT'S SICK FRO LONELY MEDIA
LEFTIST
LEISTS.
CAN YOU BLA THE
YE YOU CAN.
SHE'S G MORE GRAPE JCES THAT A.
ST OF THE QZ SHOW ONOX
NATION.
'S AS UOMFORTABLE AS A
MIDD SEATN COACHETWEEN A
UPLE ARGUI ABO SNKS.IT'S JOE.
AN SHE PSONE ALL OF YOUR
DRINKS
FOX NEWS CTRIBOR KAT TIF.
SUNNY IS COLLEGE WORTH IT?>> I .
DON'T KNOW.
>> Gre YOUIDN'T GO?
>> GOT SKY HIGSCHOOL
I SPENT ANTIR YEAR TRYINTO
RECUPERATE.
BY THE TIM IT S OVER I WAS
INHE REET
Greg: AND YOUIDN' MISSIT.>> NO.
WHEN IAD MY DAUGER, I
DEDED TO LEARNOMETNG SO
YOU CAN TEA THIS LITE ONE THAT .
U BLAME T SCHOOL FOR .THE SCHL T
THEY STARTED WITHS WITHCAPTAINP.
LIKE BK EN, IFOUANTED TO
BE ONE O THE CL ONES YOU
WANT TO  A ANETEER.
EY SRTEDS VERY YOUNG BEINGPETRI
DISAEAR IF WE DARTMENT DO
ERYTHING IOUR POWER TO
COAT CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE FUNNY TNG WAS, NON OFS
NTEDO BE PLANETEERS
NO.
WE WTED TO JUMP IN THEONEY
PI
NO MATTER H MAN TIMES YOU
SH T INDOCTNATI, WHEN WE
GE TOAKEHE CHCE, WE'RE
ALWA GOING TO COSE TOUMP
IN T MONEY PIT.
THAT ISY -- HOW I SHOULD GIVE
OPLECOMFORT.
AS LONG ASOU GEAPITISM
>> Greg: IT'SO TRUE.IN OU
SO TR.
INEAD,HAT -- THEY' PUSHINGTHESE
NO THE CITALT LANE
ONERR LATE THEY HAV TO
REALIZ TO YOUR POINT, THE
PLANET CREATEDCNCTAIN
TEDTURNER.
RIT?
I DN'T KNOW THAT
>> Greg: A LOT OF TNGS YOU
DOT OW.
>>URPOSELY FOR INDOCTRINATI.
WE THI THEY'RE TRYING
ENTEAIN.
TH'RE NOT TRYINTO ENTERTAIN.
AND DOING I FOR DECADES>> Greg:
>> I DO, GREG.STURBING.
[LAUTER]
I THIN -- OBVIOUSLY THE
VIROENT IS NOT OY IMPORTAN IT'
ROIT, GREG.
WAS IRESSED BY THE IRON CLA
LOGIC OF THE UDENTS.
>> I LE TT RL'S REASON FONOT GI.
I TRAVEL LOT.
YOU CAN'TRGUE WITH AT.
THE ENVIRONNTAL MEMEN SHARE
ADD LOT WITHHAT HAPPENED TS
YEAR WITH T HYSRIA OVERHE
ENVIRONMEN ANDHE HYSTEA
ERVID.
E SAME PEOESED E SAME
TAICSO SCARE PEOPLE.
>> Gg: I THIOU'RE OFF
BASE.
>> I'M NOTFF BASE
I'M SO O BE-
>>reg: YOU CAN'T GET ME OU>> GR
I GUESSPPRESSED WN WHITE
OPLE START YELLING.CALMDOWN.
SHAME ONOU FOR SINGOVIDIS AL.
MAKE AREAT POIN
OF COUE IS REAL, BUT THE
ARE USG, THE ST DOWN OFHE
ECONOMY.
THE VIRONMENTALISTTHEY NEVEALLY
>> Greg: IAGREY CARE ABOUT CONTG
>> IT' LEFTISM.
TO TURN USNTO A HEALTHSTATE,
AT TY DID IS WANT T SHUT
DO THE ECONOMY.
IN THE BAAIN, THEYLSO WANT
CONTROL OUR IIVIDL
HEAL.
SO THEY'RE USING THEAME
TENIQUES.
I'M RIGHTHEREN BASE.
Greg: WHAT I TERESTING,
I'M GOINGO EDIT THAT A OUT
AND REPLA IWITH LITTLE
YOU LIKE POLES.
>> I LOVE POLES.[LAUGHTEI LIKE G
MARSHMLOWS IN BROOKSBROTHE.
>> Gre IS YR POOE WITH AWHITE A?
>> YES.
>> Gre AREOU TRIFI O
THE WHITE ACALYPSE OR THE
KIDS?>> BEINGYPOCRITE IS AWESOM.
TIME AND'LL TELLOU WT, E
YOU CAN DO THINGS LI CANCEL
THE KEYSTO PIPINE HERE AND
SUPPT THE NORD STAM PIPELININ E.
YOUANAY TT CMATE CHANG
THE MOST IMPORNT THING O
EREND HAVE JEFF BEZOS FLY A
T-SHIRT T YOU RSE.
Greg: THAT I THE
COEQUEES OF EXPLOSI OF
DEVERY FMAMAZON.
I ORDER ALMS.
I DON'T TNK ABOUT IT
TH SHOD UPVERYAY LIK
>> JEFF BEZOS I A BIG CLIMATE
ANGE ADVOCATE.HE BOUT A00 FOO C.
>> H IMPTANT IS IT TO LEARN
>> N AT ALL.MPORTANT?
I SAY IORTA A I'M
ININ BEACONFSUCCESS.
SOME MIGHT S ROLEMODEL.MANY PEO.
>>reg: TRUE.
>> HOPE NOT.
DON'T THINK- I THINKT'S-
SO GLAD YOU SD SOMETHING ABO
AND THE WHITEEOPL THAT SAID CRI.
WE ND ME PEOPLE OF COL IN
THES POSITIONS BHEY STA IN
I'M NOT SURE IT'S BECSE CIS
OMO, FORAMPL IS JT
DOIN UNPARALLED WOR FOR T
BLACK COMMUNITY.
NOBODY ELSE COULDVER
IMPOANTL DO IT.
THINK WHERE A LOT OF THIS
COMES FRO ISECAUSE I DON'TF
THEYHINK ABOUT IT THAT FA
EY KNOW TT THEY NEEDO SAY
SO THE CAN ACTLLYTAY IN
CANCELLED.HOW EAS IST TO DO TH?
THENE WAY WRE THE IT S
LIKE COD, A LOTF PEOPLE
DIDN'T WANT IT TO SP BECAUSE
TH'S THE EASIEST VTUAL SIGNAL A.
YOUTAY ME AND DO NOTHG.
>> WR MASKS.
WE DIDOU AGR WITH KAT AND
NO ME?
>> Gg: YOU'RE CRAZY, M.